la marée noire mexicaine l'équipe
d'antenne 2 s'est rendu à quelques
mètres du cratère pétrolier
sociales nouvelles mises en garde des
syndicats à son tour georges séguy
critique violemment le gouvernement
feint de la transat en double et deux
derniers de l'épreuve avec 39 jours de
retard en direct dans ce journal
mesdames et messieurs bonsoir nous
commencerons par ce qui devient hélas la
plus grande pollution de la mer que l'on
n'ait jamais enregistrée depuis plus de
deux mois dans le golfe du mexique c'est
une catastrophe sans nom le 3 juin un
puits de pétrole sous-marin a sauté il
crache chaque jour 4000 tonnes de
pétrole à ce jour il a ainsi jeté dans
la mer deux cent quarante mille tonnes
c'est à dire la quantité totale déversée
il y a un an lors de la catastrophe de
l'amoco cadiz désormais donc celle ci
est dépassée nous envoyés spéciaux alain
valentini et christian giroux ont réussi
un exploit technique en filmant
exactement ce que l'on appelle le
cratère le volcan sous-marin si vous
voulez qui crache son pétrole dans les
eaux et dont les nappes avance de 20 à
30 kilomètres par jour vers les côtes du
texas
il aura donc fallu attendre deux mois
deux mois pour que les mexicains
apprennent par leurs journaux la vérité
sur la sphère d'ixtoc 1 mais il faut
aller à ciudad del carmen pour mesurer
l'ampleur de la catastrophe
première surprise sur l'aéroport de la
petite île du golfe du mexique des
dizaines de milliers de barils de
dispersants qui attendent d'être utilisé
en pleine mer
bien je voudrais demander ce que nous
faisons ce sujet s'est arrêtée comme
prévu oui
pas son problème français nous verrons
bien si nous pouvons tous aller
retourner au mexique pour les français
en général c'est encore un période des
vacances en fait nous sommes exactement
en son milieu mais deux des principaux
leaders syndicalistes submergeront
slater général de force ouvrière et
monsieur georges séguy serait de la cgt
n'ont pas attendu la rentrée l'un et
l'autre ont fait des mises en garde
sévère aux pouvoirs publics monsieur
bergeron dans une interview ce matin à
notre confrère leur or avertit le
gouvernement qu'il ne faut pas dépasser
certaines limites il se réfère aux
récentes hausses des prix qui dit il
ampute sérieusement le pouvoir d'achat
des salariés il prévoit que la rentrée
sociale sera plus difficile que l'année
dernière en conséquence monsieur
bergeron demeure d'une augmentation du
smic est aussi un accroissement
substantiel de la prime de rentrée
scolaire pour les familles ayant des
enfants à l'école quand on signe et il
va plus loin pour lui les limites du
supportable pour les salariés sont déjà
dépassés le cumul de l'augmentation des
cotisations de la sécurité sociale
de la diminution des prestations
des hausses de prix et pour beaucoup de
l'accroissement des charges fiscales se
traduit par une brutale l'amputation du
pouvoir d'achat des travailleurs
calculé sur une année c'est une ponction
de près d'un mois de salaire dont sera
victime le smicard
ce n'est plus de l'austérité c'est de la
spoliation
la brutalité de la teinte pouvoir
d'achat justifie le versement immédiat
d'une augmentation minime à 200 francs
par mois à valoir sur la revalorisation
des salaires négociés par branche
justifie le blocage des prix
la revalorisation des prestations
familiales et une allocation de rentrée
scolaire de 600 francs par enfant
une taxe de 1% sur les grosses fortunes
qui dispose de 10% du poids du
patrimoine national
la taxation de 0 5 % des profits des
grandes sociétés
monsieur georges séguy sera l'invité
demain indirects d'antenne 2010 je
reviendrai au problème français dans un
instant pour le moment nous repartons
vers le golfe du mexique afin de voir
c'est extraordinaire c'est épouvantable
marée noire qui s'avance vers les côtes
du texas
il aura donc fallu attendre deux mois
deux mois pour que les mexicains
apprennent par leurs journaux la vérité
sur la sphère d'ixtoc 1 mais il faut
aller à ciudad del carmen pour mesurer
l'ampleur de la catastrophe
première surprise sur l'aéroport de la
petite île du golfe du mexique des
dizaines de milliers de barils de
dispersants qui attendent d'être utilisé
en pleine mer
la deuxième surprise et on a beau y être
préparé elle nous attend après un vol de
45 minutes en hélicoptère appartenant à
la pemex la compagnie dé pétrole
mexicain toute puissante dans la région
lorsque l'on arrive enfin près de la
plate forme la mer est véritablement en
feu
eh bien nous sommes ici à peu près 30
mètres du cratère il faut absolument une
chaleur intenable 50 à 60 degrés il y a
environ une centaine de personnes qui
sont sur ce bateau enfin d'asperger le
foyer malheureusement peut pas bien
revanche on le pétrole d'ixtoc puis
depuis le 3 juin et selon les ingénieurs
de québec il n'y aura absolument aucun
moyen d'arrêter cette fuite avant la mi
septembre date de la finition des deux
puits parallèles
ici s'est levé il est environ deux mois
la plateforme flottante d'ixtoc 1
aujourd'hui elle a complètement disparu
à 50 mètres de profondeur le problème ce
sont les obturateurs réduit à l'état de
carcasse qui gisent peugeot 6 ou la mère
de l'enchevêtrement de leurs tuyaux
s'échappe donc le pétrole qui jaillet la
surface avec une formidable pression
première solution imaginée par pemex le
colmatage du puits et ce sont des hommes
grenouilles qui sont chargés de cette
mission des spécialistes qui travaillent
quelques mètres des flammes dans un
océan de pétrole risquant à tout moment
de s'enflammer à son tour le danger est
énorme et pourtant devant cette fuite
ininterrompu de pétrole ces sommes ne
peuvent pas faire grand chose
deuxième solution le travail de pompage
d'une centaine d'ouvriers qui se
relaient 24 heures sur 24 sur cette
plateforme
pour eux il s'agit de refroidir
constamment c'est énorme tuyau qui
aspire le pétrole là aussi le danger
certain mais les résultats sont minimes
par rapport à la quantité de pétrole qui
n'en finit pas de jaillir de la mer
troisième parade des autorités
mexicaines les barrages installés entre
les bateaux peine perdue la nappe les a
déjà traversé puisqu'elle atteint en ce
moment même le littoral américain au
niveau du texas
reste le meilleur espoir d'enrayer cette
marée noire le captage du pétrole en
parallèle par deux autres plateformes
comme celle que l'on vienne voir les
mexicains creuse en ce moment sous la
mer à 800 mètres de distance depuis qu
ici les calculs des experts sont bons
devraient atteindre le gisement d'ixtoc
un à droite et à gauche afin de soulager
la pression du puits en éruption le
problème c'est que le selon les
autorités de pemex les travaux ne seront
pas terminés avant la mi septembre
et ça termine à notre cour de justice a
déterminé que c'était un accident et non
pas une négligence
sous serre alors un accident peut
arriver dans n'importe quelle activité
si vous ne sortez pas de votre maison
les bienvenus aurait jamais d'accident
si en revanche montrés tels que les
choses aient sauvé toujours un vrai
alors pour prévoir ces accidents et bien
il y aller mais celui ci nous servira
d'expérience car nous allons continuer
nos forages dans la mer parce que c'est
une zone il fait trouve ixtoc 1 3 ferme
des gisements très important pour
l'avenir
et pendant ce temps le puits continue de
cracher son pétrole il y a deux mois
c'était la plus grande catastrophe d'un
puits offshore aujourd'hui selon tous
les experts c'est la plus grande
catastrophe écologique de tous les temps
pas d'accord répond des mexicains cela
n'est pas aussi grave jusqu'à la
puissante compagnie des pêches concernés
au premier chef qui refuse de
reconnaître la réalité face à cet
optimisme forcené il existe quand même
des mexicains qui essaient d'alerter le
gouvernement de la catastrophe en cours
ce sont des scientifiques qui ont abouti
à des résultats alarmants sur la faune
et la flore de la région le problème
c'est que l'on refuse de les entendre on
ne vous a pas demandé de participer on
ne vous a pas aidés non
jamais
est-ce que vous avez proposer vos
services
pour ses services nous avons un breguet
fait un étude
la pollution
spécifique le gros problème est bien
c'est que les espèces qui n'ont pas été
détruites par la pollution sont
maintenant contaminée pour l'absorption
de ces fruits de mer contaminés et qui
sont hautement cancérigène doit donc
être
existé
deux cent mille tonnes de pétrole sont
déjà sortis de ce puits en éruption au
moins autant continueront à se déverser
avant la fin des travaux de colmatage au
mieux à la mi septembre et d'ici là il
n'y a strictement rien à faire
je reviens aux questions français josé
dit tout à l'heure que monsieur séguy
serai demain l'invité voire 20 2010 et
après demain jeudi c'est monsieur robert
boulin ministre du travail qui sera
notre invité monsieur lula avec lequel
nous ferons le tour de l'ensemble des
problèmes actuels dans son secteur de
manière à vous renseigner le plus
complètement possible
je vous donnerai d'autre indication à ce
sujet de monsieur michel baraton délégué
général de l'udf a annoncé que l'union
pour la démocratie française allait
lancer prochainement une campagne pour
expliquer aux français pourquoi la
situation actuelle est difficile
monsieur pinton a déclaré faire toi
limoges les français s'apercevront vite
que des choses sont difficiles et qu'il
ne faut pas s'attendre à des miracles
dans la situation économique actuelle le
rôle de l' agence nationale pour
l'emploi là une paix est d'une très
grande importance puisque c'est par elle
que passe la majorité des offres
d'emploi et des demandes d'emploi elle a
donc beaucoup à faire et l'autre jour
monsieur beaudoin son directeur général
est venu ici même pour nous faire part
des difficultés qu'elle éprouve
notamment le surcroît de besoins
administrative que lui impose
l'obligation du pointage des chômeurs
autre difficulté lorsqu'un employeur
offre du travail il n'a pas le droit de
faire preuve de discrimination puisque
la loi interdit toute discrimination
raciale ou religieuse
or la haine peut se voit ta portée
parfois des offres d'emploi à caractère
raciste elles ne sont pas nombreuses
existe et voici lagence placé dans une
situation ambiguë dans les annonces de
l'agencé nationale pour l'emploi un
employeur précise pas de nord africains
tandis qu'un autre exige la nationalité
française
les tiroirs de l'anpe sont plaints de ce
genre d' annonce et l'offre d'emploi
nettes alors présenté comme personne
répondant aux critères les autres
candidats ignorent souvent la
discrimination dont ils sont l'objet est
un concours de circonstance est parfois
nécessaire pour qu'il apprenne
à
la personne parce que je savais j'avais
eu des cas de racisme et la dame avait
téléphoné pour demander si on rit des
embauches en gérant du courrier quand
elle a précisé la nationalité
on amorce la place parce que détiennent
charia j'espère
interrogés les employeurs fournissent
toujours de bonnes d'excusés
malheureusement des garçons qui sont
venus qui n'avait pas du tout leurs la
possibilité de parler de s'exprimer et
alors c'est pour ça on avait demandé
quelqu'un qui parle vraiment le français
nous avons un certain comme toute
entreprise un certain quota de personnel
étranger à utiliser et dans notre
effectif actuellement nous sommes rendus
à la limite maximum de notre côté dans
voulait simplement éviter de renouveler
les essais pour éviter les déconvenues
j'avais du personnel aussi bien pour les
gens qui viennent pour nous mêmes et
également pour l'ambiance à l'intérieur
de l'atelier
refuser à ses hommes à ces femmes un
travail à cause de la couleur de leur
peau est interdit par la loi pourtant de
telles discriminations sont autorisés à
condition que l'employeur fournissent un
motif légitime mais c'est alors aux
tribunaux d'en juger position délicate
pour l'anpe qui a déjà plusieurs
reprises est inculpé pour racisme
l'inculpé parce que dans les fichiers de
lagence il y avait des offres qui
présentait des indications relatifs à
des discriminations à dire brasse en u2
l'embauchage et vous n'avez aucun moyen
par exemple de dire tout simplement non
nous ne voulons pas aller passer ses
annonces mais dans l'état actuel des
instructions
la disposition 20 des agents il doit
seulement informer l'employeur de la
législation et si l'employeur une fois
informé persiste dans le dépôt d'offres
avec la discrimination nous sommes tenus
de l'apprendre
et de l'exploiter il est difficile que
l' agence se transforme en gendarmes si
vous voulez ou enfin où l'inspecteur
visant à juger à apprécier le bien fondé
du motif légitime car c'est contraire ça
paraît qu'on fait apparemment au
contraire à la bonne relation vous nous
voulons développer avec les entreprises
bonnes relations avec les entreprises
certes mais à quel prix les victimes du
racisme ont bien peu de chances de se
défendre en justice puisque le plus
souvent elles ignorent jusqu'à
l'existence de ces annonces
les failles de la législation actuelle
n'échappe pas aux responsables anpe qui
envisage des solutions inspirées des
lois étrangères
on pourrait songer à des dérogations qui
serait accordée par exemple par
l'inspecteur du travail aux coups bas
les gars qu'en fait on n'aurait pas le
droit de refuser quelqu'un pour sa race
la couleur au sang sexe sauf dans un cas
précis d'une des revenus une dérogation
à son système
inverse accordée par le représentant du
ministère du travail l'inspecteur du
travail
pour rendre la loi efficace il suffirait
simplement l'employeur soit obligé de
prouver à chaque fois son otite et
effectivement légitime
bison futé est content de la manière
dont tu m'as circuler en france au cours
des sept journées les plus chargées de
fin juillet et début il y avait 30 %
dans le comblement en moins et en
général la direction des routes estime
que depuis le début de l'été des
automobilistes bravo ont dans l'ensemble
bien mis à profit les conseils qu'elle
diffuse une dépêche qui vient de nous
parvenir vingt personnes selon la radio
nationale espagnole 25 selon l' agence
de presse espagnole efe sont mortes
aujourd'hui à lloret de mar dans la
catalogne à la suite d'un incendie de
forêt qui aurait selon la radio atteint
une zone urbanisée et selon lagence et
effet il aurait atteint un camping
j'aurais sans doute des précisions à la
fin de cette édition
plusieurs nageurs ont disparu cet
après-midi dans la baie de la canche une
rivière qui se jette dans la mer dont du
touquet paris plage les crs sont aidés
dans la recherche par des hélicoptères
il ya là un secteur dangereux à cause
des rouleaux qui se forment à l'endroit
précis où la canche abouti à la mer
normalement les gens ne s'y baignent pas
en fait il s'agirait aujourd'hui de
jeunes allemands qui avaient déjà été en
difficulté au même endroit d'autres
jours et qui avait dû alors faire appel
à l'équipe de maîtres nageurs sauveteurs
si cela est vrai c'est vraiment de
l'inconscience c'est jouer avec le feu
je vous rappelle en tout cas ce que nous
avons déjà dit la semaine dernière il y
à chaque année plus de 5000 personnes en
france 5000 qui partit pour prendre des
vacances ne reviennent jamais 5000
personnes par exemple c'est la
population de saint tropez en hiver
deux hommes en tout cas qui sont revenus
de leurs expéditions lointaines est sain
et sauf et nous sommes contents c'est
les lanternes rouges la transatlantique
en double et ils sont à rennes dans nos
studios gérard holtz et 10,6 à paris
duplex avoue du navigateur oui je crois
qu'on peut féliciter jean pierre cabaret
qui était le skipper et claude brun jean
pierre cabaret à gauche sur l'écran et
claude brun à droite 39 jours de retard
sur les premiers de l'épreuve c'est à
dire sur gallinae riguidel ça fait un
peu sourire mais ce que vous ça vous
fait sourire non non parce que on a fait
le maximum et on n'était pas du tout
dans les mêmes conditions on avait un
bateau très lourd et qui était le plus
petit de course donc c'est un peu normal
qu'on ait ce retard peut-être que on a
fait quelques erreurs bien sûr mais
c'est normal je pense connaître
justement parlant de bateaux égyptiens
c'était le plus lourd mais c'est aussi
le plus vieux il avait 30 ans qui est
énorme pour un atout pour un voilier de
course pour avoir des deux courses oui
parce que
maintenant les les voiliers sont bien
étudiés pour avant la vitesse tout ça
mais c'était un bateau qui était en
avance en 1949 sur son temps et
sa coque sapho sa carène était très bien
réfugié en fin de compte il va assez
vite quand même quoi il est idiot 49
qu'une foule dit mais peut-être pas
aujourd'hui ce n'était pas un pari un
peu fou comme ça de partir faire la
transat en double
non ce n'est pas par une foule
c'est surtout pour nous je crois moi ça
a été la fête la nuit dernière à lorient
il ya eu les binious pour vous
accueillir bon est-ce que ça a été la
fête à bord pendant toute la traversée
ce qui appauvrit des moments difficiles
quand même
ça jamais j'ai pas été souvent la fête à
voir pour les plans parti faire du
tourisme ni ni faire une petite balade
refait notre transat avec nos moyens et
notre bateau et je crois que c'était dur
mais eu des moments durs et des buts des
bons moments comme tout le monde
quel a été le moment le plus difficile
le plus difficile je crois qu'on était
en arrive aux bermudes ouais on a eu
cinq jours devant de france du
5 6 fois plus et oui avec des rafales en
moyenne quoi missa est
bon ben ça et qui très dur d'arriver la
brouille quoi et une fois qu'on a viré
la bouée mais les vents ont tourné aussi
et ça fait qu'on est reparti avec bonne
foi ça c'est vrai vous avez sabler le
champagne après avoir viré la bouée ah
ouais comme il faut mieux
en barrant s'était pas c'était
formidable vous êtes arrivé à lorient
avec qu'est-ce qui vous restez comme
comme alimentation en bas une rester
comme dans la pub du chien route
pour la tombe et se révoltent ont alors
profité dans les fonds il y allait y
avait du tronc ça marche très bien
être 72 jours sur un bateau comme ça est
ce que c'est pas de temps en temps la
galère quand même d'être à deux sur un
bateau non non on s'habitue vous n'êtes
pas discuté au bond et des coups de
gueule avec un leclerc s'énerve parce
que le vent revient c'est fini le calme
mais dans les moments difficiles non non
ça n'a jamais fait pas d'ombré se
permettre dans le coup devant tout ça
n'est pas question de sorts et vous
n'étiez pas un petit peu jaloux des
premiers de ce qu'on appelle les formule
1 de la mer avec leur équipement non on
se dit maintenant que si on leur faisait
une on le ferait dans les séries faire
dans les meilleures conditions quoi
pourra venir chance quand parce que
c'est sûr que traîner comme ça
dans toutes manières de le départ on
n'était pas partir et que moto
compétitive donc on pouvait pas être
compétitif on n'était pas partis dans
cet esprit là non plus on était parti
pour faire la course pour participer
quoi ipass déterminer où et pour nous il
traîne avec du retard
bravo
nous revenons aux dossiers
internationaux après l'annoncé de
l'accord de paix entre la mauritanie et
le front polisario il n'y a toujours pas
de réaction officielle marocaine
toutefois après les récentes mises en
garde du roi hassan ii il ne semble pas
que le maroc puisse accepter la création
d'un état sahraoui qui lui soit hostile
la marche verte de 1975 qui avait pour
but de contraindre l'espagne à rendre au
maroc le territoire du sahara occidental
illustre bien la farouche détermination
du roi hassan 2 de ne pas se laisser
déposséder des terres qu'ils estiment
marocaine par l'histoire et par le droit
après le partage du sahara occidental
entre le maroc et la mauritanie
hier éclatait la nouvelle que les
mauritaniens avaient signé la paix avec
le front polisario que soutient algérie
et qu'il renonçait à toutes leurs
revendications territoriales désormais
le maroc se retrouve ce mot cette année
à l'oni tous ses engagements et sans me
consulter et ça vous dit quoi que ce
soit et pas ces six agissements met en
danger notre sécurité sur le flanc sud
de l'europe et
voilà comment jugent un petit peu la
situation
alors pour faire
naturellement
déjà avancé décision sa majesté banques
la voix la plus autorisée au maroc avait
déjà mis en garde la mauritanie en
disant que le maroc ne peut admettre que
la mauritanie se défasse de ses
engagements mais les engagements et que
en ce moment il prendra ses
responsabilités parce que si nous avons
cédé à la mauritanie un certain moment
une partie ce sahara que nous avons
toujours réclamé entièrement aujourd'hui
dit tout à l'heure et oxyde l'endroit où
vous vient à nous ce droit de préemption
beaucoup plus que d'autres et en plus il
n'est pas possible pour nous de nous
trouver en cercle et pas une république
où un vous quels qu'ils soient qui
viendra mettre en danger
les dérives entière sud et nous couper
avec l'afrique avec la mauritanie alors
que peut faire que que doit faire le
maroc l'acte et le maroc je peux vous le
garantir
prendra ses responsabilités pour
défendre son intégrité territoriale
ils peuvent sauvegarder tease acquis
historiques je ne vous dirai pas
exactement de quoi il s'agit vous le
verrez c'est un mandat du prochain jeu
le président carter a publiquement
souhaité à baltimore aux etats-unis une
diminution importante de l'affluence du
parti communiste en italie j'ai été très
satisfait dit il des résultats des
dernières élections en italie qui se
sont traduites par une perte
substantielle du soutien populaire au
parti communiste c'est ce qu'il a
déclaré alors qu'il s'adressait à un
groupe d'américains à 120,6 tanière en
iran la presse est dans le collimateur
dirons nous la nouvelle loi sur la
presse adopté hier dit je cite que tout
article calomnieux ou contraire à la
vérité concernant le leader de la
révolution
le futur président de la république ou
son premier ministre entraînera des
poursuites d'office et une peine de
prison l'équipe de nos confrères de la
télévision américaine nbc est expulsé et
elle s'est entendue dire que le conseil
de la révolution avait décidé
d'interdire pendant deux mois l'entrée
en iran aux journalistes étrangers alors
d'autre part les gardiens de la
révolution est occupé aujourd'hui les
imprimeries d'un journal considéré à
terrain comme le reflet de l'opposition
laïque à l'ayatollah khomeini ce journal
à yaoundé gagnent ce qui signifie me dit
on les hommes du futur et d'accusé
d'avoir été créés grâce de l'argent de
la cia et du contre-espionnage israélien
et de la savak la police politique du
chat demain nous vous présenterons un
reportage de philippe rochot sur la vie
quotidienne en iran reportage tourné
vous le pensez bien avec mille
difficultés réfugiés du vietnam dans
antenne 2010 monsieur ron van phong
ambassadeur du vietnam affirmé que les
mesures de moratoire décidé à genève ne
freinerait en rien les migrations de
vietnamiens qu'ils désirent quitter leur
pays voici le passage essentiel de
l'interview de monsieur robinson
vous précisez bien personne ne sera
contraint de partir et personne ne soit
empêché de partir gare enfin pourquoi
est-ce qu'il ya tous ces départs sauvage
c'est parce que les gens ont peur que
les uns qu'on les empêche de partir il
ya deux choses tout d'abord et la peur
de la guerre
et puis il ya ces appels de la voix de
l'amérique sortez sortez vous avez des
bateaux américaine
syfy channel répartition ambassadeur
même ses appels de sienne n'aurait pas
de résultat
et il ya aussi des gens qui souhaitent
partir vous revient à ceux d'aujourd'hui
le pré tout à l'heure ryad et bixente la
première nous avons souhaité que les
jeunes restent mais c'est comme dans une
grande famille nous renouvelons il ya un
ou deux qui fouette dans les moments
difficiles de la famille à les haïr
travail et nous laisser partir puis 13
vous espérez que reviendront mais il ya
des gens qui partent non dans ce cas
nous avons discuté avec le haut
commissariat pour un plan ne les pas de
ces gens noble art s alors ces gens-là
s'inscrivent sur les listes et ils
partiront vous artistique que dans le
cadre de cet ordre tout le monde tous
ceux qui demanderaient un visa de départ
tout le monde recevra son visa départ
tous ceux qui désirent partir nous ne
les résolvons pas de face la page
médicale à lyon on attends tu es à
l'hôpital edouard herriot une opération
d'une extrême difficulté la greffe de la
moelle osseuse le sujet est un bébé de
neuf points et il a fallu lui transférer
1 milliards de cellules de moelle
osseuse pour qu'il puisse se défendre
contre des microbes auquel il se
trouvait être complètement vulnérable
l'opération a été faite par l'équipe du
docteur touraine élue des perpétuelles
un reportage de fr3 la greffe de moelle
osseuse réalisé sur ce bébé n'est pas
une nouveauté la première a été
effectuée à minneapolis en 1968 depuis
une cinquantaine de transplantation de
ce type ont été effectués dans le monde
dont la moitié à lyon et à paris ce qui
différencie cette greffe des autres
c'est le type très particulier de
déficit immunitaire dont souffre l
enfant une maladie découverte il y a
cinq ans à lyon par le docteur touraine
et qui reste très rare beaucoup plus
original par contre est la greffe de
cellules de foetus cette grève destinée
elle aussi à combattre le déficit
immunitaire a été réalisée avec succès
pour la première fois au monde à lyon il
y a trois ans mais c'est aujourd'hui
seulement que le dr touraine sûr du
résultat rend la nouvelle publique
lorsqu'il n'existe pas de donneur de
moelle osseuse compatible on est obligé
de s'orienter vers une autre possibilité
man de reconstitution immunitaire par un
une greffe de tissus foetale greffe de
foie et de thymus pétales et nous avons
eu la chance il y a trois ans maintenant
de pouvoir en modifiant un peu la
technique antérieurs réalisés ce
traitement chez un enfant qui est
actuellement en bonne santé ne nécessite
plus de traitements et représente seul
enfant qui a pu survivre le plus
longtemps grâce à cette variété de
traitements bien qu'il n'ait pas de
donneur de moelle osseuse compatible
dans toute la vaste population où nous
avons fait nos recherches c'est à dire à
l'échelle européenne il n'y a pas de
donneur compatible
malgré sa l'enfant maintenant vie alors
qu'il ya quatre ans il aurait été
condamné un cratère de l'etna et 1
depuis plus de 50 ans s'est rallumée cet
après-midi ce qui est une chose
exceptionnelle et il fait preuve d'une
intense activité les versants salade qui
progresse à 5 km à l'heure et se dirige
vers le village de salles pétition à 15
kilomètres du volcan les vulcanologues
estime que l'etna est en prêt lors ce
qu'ils appellent une phase imprévisible
en fait depuis une semaine un peu
partout la terre bouge elle gronde hier
c'était un tremblement de terre de san
francisco et à légers séismes ainsi
mairie tous ces jours derniers les pnas
brisage philippe dumez nous explique les
raisons possibles de la poussée de
température de notre bonne vieille terre
la terre bouge en tout cas son écorce ce
n'est pas très nouveau puisque l'on peut
dire sans grande erreur que cela dure
depuis sa naissance il y a quatre
milliards et demi d'années
cette écorce terrestre est composé de
plaques qui se déplacent qui
s'entrechoquent qui s'éloignent les unes
des autres à chaque mouvement la terre
tremble et on estime le nombre de ces
tremblements à un million par an aux
endroits de fractures un volcan apparaît
souvent c'est ainsi que l'etna peut
entrer en éruption la faille saint-andré
à en californie se déplaçait à vingt
mille kilomètres de là il n'y a pas
forcément de rapport entre les deux
certains scientifiques pensent que
l'activité du soleil pourraient avoir
pourtant une influence sur ces
mouvements de l'écorcé terrestre et ce à
des périodes régulières mais rien n'est
encore sûr
partout dans le monde les spécialistes
ses forces en tout cas de mieux
connaître tous ces phénomènes et la
façon dont ils sont provoqués afin
d'arriver un jour à prévoir et donc à
essayer de limiter les dégâts mais
rassurons nous il n'y a que rarement des
catastrophes et aucun des signes actuels
ne laisse prévoir un gros cataclysme
malheureusement on sait généralement où
ils vont se produire n'est jamais quand
monsieur bernard lefort qui dirigeait
jusqu'ici le célèbre festival
d'aix-en-provence prendra l'année
prochaine la direction de l'opéra de
paris en remplacement de monsieur rolf
lieberman monsieur bernard lefort sera
lui remplacé à la tête du festival
d'aix-en-provence par monsieur louis
algoud qui depuis dix huit ans dirige
l'opéra de lyon et qui est metteur en
scène de théâtre lyrique et qui fut de
1973 jusqu'à l'année dernière chargé de
l'opéra studio
nouveau mode de locomotion seront
distance peut générer absolument pas
polluant la patinette ils sont en tout
cas si jeune néerlandais venue de leur
capital est à paris à patine est une
pièce de 660 km il s'agit de six
étudiants en technologie aéronautique
qui ont conçu et patinettes eux mêmes en
vertu de la règle qui peut le plus peut
le moins dix jours pour couvrir 660 km 4
à 5 heures de voyage par jour
tranquillement en regardant les paysages
vitesse maximale valeur alors ils ont vu
paris il reparle demain et laurent gens
sont mises en vente si vous voulez
rencontrer dans les années de la
capitale vous pouvez leur demander leurs
prix j'ai une dépêche qui me vient à
propos de l'incendié alors est del mar
20 personnes ont trouvé la mort dans un
incendie
celui ci s'est déclaré dans le
lotissement l'as pignard est situé à
lloret del mar dans la province de
gérone en catalogne
la majorité des victimes seraient des
enfants les occupants d'une tente
dressée sur un terrain du lotissement
figurent parmi les victimes il n'est pas
encore possible de fournir l'identité
n'ont plus que la nationalité des
victimes
la météo pour demain et bien sûr les
flandres la picardie et le bassin
parisien ciel nuageux le matin avec
quelques ondées mode temps dans
l'après-midi sur le reste du pays temps
ensoleillé et très chaud dans le midi et
des orages éclateront dans le jura et
les alpes notre édition est terminée ce
soir eric ou prou devra mes dernières
informations
n'oubliez pas demain antenne 2010
présenté par daniel bilalian et si vous
le voulez bien nous nous retrouverons
ici même à mater bonsoir merci